Hallo Leute, da bin ich mal wieder.
Soll streamvorschau refreshen.
Moment, was?
Seriously?
Was ist das denn?
Was zum Teufel?
Was ist das?
Passt mal auf.
What the fuck?
Passt mal auf, was ist das denn?
Das hab ich auch noch nie gesehen.
What?
Seit wann gibt es denn diese Meldung?
Habt ihr die jemals schon gesehen?
Ich nicht.
Also für mich ist das komplett neu.
Das gab es doch nie.
Man musste die ganze Zeit
seine Streams
selbst als
erwachsene
Audience kennzeichnen,
wenn man zu sehr rumgeflucht hat und sonst was.
Alter, seriously, Battlefield
is maturated.
Also langsam wird es ja echt
lächerlich hier.
Wollen die das alle zu Kick rennen oder was?
Was nicht passieren wird.
Wobei.
Naja, ein bisschen Konkurrenz
sagt man ja immer belebt das Geschäft.
Aber Kick wirkt halt so
krass shady und glücksspiel
fokussiert, dass es eher
nix ist, wo ich
drauf setzen würde.
Nee, muss ich nicht, weil ich müsste es kaufen
und ich will es nicht kaufen in dem jetzigen Zustand.
Also ich hab ja den letzten
Playtest gespielt und ehrlich gesagt,
ich bin nicht so scharf drauf, mir das zu kaufen.
30 Euro auch noch oder was?
Hatten die nicht ursprünglich 15?
Ach doch, hier, 15.
Die haben 15 gesagt.
Ich mein, vielleicht
sind die auch mega
krass ist, was passiert. Kann ja sein.
Gucken wir mal kurz.
Naja gut, das gab es halt vorher so nicht.
Ja, mal schauen.
Ist halt die Frage, also der letzte
Playtest, der hat sich jetzt für mich
noch nicht so angefühlt, als will ich das wirklich
länger, länger spielen oder
als will ich da Geld für ausgeben.
Mal gespannt. Ja Leute, habt ihr auch
alle jetzt diesen
erwachsene Audience-Sache
bekommen bei mir auf Twitch?
Das gibt es erst, guck hier,
das gibt es erst seit heute.
Weiß nicht, was das sein soll.
Keine Ahnung.
Ja, ich glaube auf
Ich glaube, auf Mobile
kriegt man es nicht, gell?
Ich glaube,
auf Mobile gibt es das nicht.
Echt? Okay.
Also im Browser hatte ich es jetzt,
aber auf Mobile, ich habe eben extra
meinen eigenen Stream auf Mobile aufgemacht.
Da war nix.
Ich mach mal das Game an.
Update required.
Okay.
Hä? Warum muss ich jetzt updaten?
Ich habe das vor 5 Minuten gestartet,
da war noch kein Update da. Aber okay.
Ich mein, ich will mich mal nicht
beschweren. Machen wir ein Update, wenn es sein muss.
Mal gucken, ob
der Heap heute wieder mitspielen will.
Den hatten wir letztens hier.
Richtiger 5-Förder-Heli-Flieger.
Da haben wir jede Rush-Runde easy gewonnen,
wo es Helis gab. Und wir hatten
die letzte Erika-Harber-Runde, die war wirklich
mega nice. Irgendwie 70 Kills oder
Andy 70 Kills.
Ich mach kein Video zu
Season 5, weil
Season 5 ist jetzt schon 2 Wochen alt.
Ich mach so ein Lohnt-sich-das-Game-jetzt
Video, weil das quasi
auch das ist, was zu
irgendwie
der Hälfte der Fragen
ist. Ah Max, lohnt sich das jetzt?
Okay. Mobile auch.
Battle-Bit will ich mir nicht kaufen.
Ich hab den letzten, oder noch nicht.
Ich hab mir den letzten
Early-Access-Test gespielt und das hat
sich doch noch sehr, sehr
experimentell
trifft's, glaub ich, ganz gut
angefühlt.
Ich mein, es sei denn, die haben jetzt
mit allen Updates gewartet für Early-Access
und hauen jetzt richtig krass raus.
Also vielleicht, vielleicht ist
es ja doch. Vielleicht kauf ich mir noch.
Ich mein, ich will jetzt nicht großen Akt machen.
15 Euro. Okay.
Was sagst du, was gefällt dir an dem
Game am besten?
Überzeugt mich mal.
Also wie gesagt, ich hab die Early-Access-Sachen
ja gespielt und irgendwie wirkte
das noch sehr, ja,
experimentell ist vielleicht das
falsche Wort, sehr mit
heißer Nadel gestrickt alles.
Und
es hat sich auch vom Gameplay so angefühlt, als
du hattest nie eine Ahnung, was dich jetzt genau
gekillt hat. Es war sehr merkwürdig.
Okay, können wir jetzt spielen?
Wir müssen mal schauen, dass
der Sound nicht zu laut ist. Bei dem Game
weiß man nämlich nie. Battlefield resettet
auch mal ganz gerne die Sound-Settings.
Eine Runde
Nintendo-Musik kurz aus.
Battlefield.
Jawoll.
Ne, das wollte ich eigentlich gar nicht.
Aber auch ganz gut.
Ich wollte die Menü-Musik.
Die Menü-Musik von
Battlefield 1.
Extremly
Hog ist.
Und das kann man halt noch
Musik nennen.
Ja, oder Soundtrack.
Das, was das Game
hat.
Nicht wirklich, ne?
Das Game hat ja quasi keinen Soundtrack.
Außer, ich versuche mal
kurz den Battlefield-Soundtrack zu machen.
Außer
...
So, ungefähr so
hört sich der Battlefield 2042-Soundtrack
an. Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob das durch mein
Noise-Canceling und
RX-Voice und
so nicht durchgekommen ist, oder ob das gedacht hat
bei mir im Hintergrund läuft ein Föhn.
Weiß nicht, ob man da was gehört hat.
Okay, let's go.
Oh, wir haben glaube ich die
neue Waffe unlockt, oder?
Guck mal, wir sind doch jetzt Battle Pass
28.
Hä?
Wir sind Battle Pass 28?
Oder muss man
erst 29 sein?
Hä?
Ich bin 27,
aber bin auf...
Die Anzeige ist aber echt pepega, oder?
Man würde eigentlich erwarten, dort wo man ist,
das hat man jetzt, dort wo man drauf ist
und man bekommt... Naja, okay.
Was auch immer, das ist das kleinste Problem,
was das Game hat.
Das ist
wirklich das kleinste Problem.
Oh, geht schon los. Instant Match.
Streams to Battle Bit.
Du bist jetzt schon der Fünfte, der fragt.
Also, eigentlich
hatte ich es nicht vor, aber ich mein,
wenn ihr da so scharf
drauf seid...
Ich mein, 15 Euro sind jetzt ja nicht
die Welt. Ich muss halt sagen, der letzte
Playtest, den ich gespielt hab, der hat mich
jetzt nicht so wahnsinnig überzeugt.
Oh, easy Runde.
Leute, by the way, die Map ist verbuggt.
Vielleicht haben sie es auch gefixt, aber ich glaube
nicht. Zentrix, danke schön für den Sub.
Ich glaube nicht, dass sie es gefixt haben.
Übrigens, erste Runde, ich hab mich auf 0 eingespielt und sonst war's.
Also, preparet euch mal ein bisschen für
Hardcore Pepega-Aim.
Übrigens, das wird easy Defender-Runde,
weil Defender...
Äh, was laber ich denn?
Ähm, nicht Defender.
Weil die Attacker-Boote nicht richtig respawnen.
Äh, wartet mal, wartet mal.
Lautstärke?
Bis sie leise, oder?
Hat das irgendwas am Sound rumgestellt wieder?
Oder, sagt mal, wie gesagt,
ich kann es schlecht einschätzen,
weil es bei euch so ist.
Oh, ich muss mich erst mal ordentlich hinsetzen,
da ich was spielen kann.
Erst mal kurz checken, wie ist denn hier in OBS?
Ne, geht eigentlich.
Ich glaub, ich... Oh, oh, fuck, da ist ein Gegner.
Ich kack nur, Alter.
Na geil, sehr gut gemacht, Max.
Richtig, richtig six-head-time.
Die sind auf dem Dach und ich bin runtergefallen
und mein Grappling-Hook
ist nicht am Start.
Okay, alles.
Kein Problem. Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Die Legehenne ist am Start.
Oh, massive, massive aim, massive aim.
Geilstes aim ever.
Habt ihr noch nie gesehen, sowas hier.
Ultra, ultrakrasses.
Äh.
Den hab ich nicht gesehen.
Wo kam der her?
Die beste Balance in dem Game war doch wohl
als die Flagge in dem... Ja, ja, ja.
Wait a minute, wir verlieren ernsthaft?
Wir verlieren gerade... Seriously?
Wir verlieren Nosha, Kennels,
Defense?
Ernsthaft?
Ist das... Seriously? Ist das euer Ernst?
Oh, das war ganz blöd
zu reloaden.
Ich weiß jetzt nicht, wo er herkommt.
Okay, ja, nice.
Kannst halt...
Oh.
Moin.
Man kann doch, man kann doch
ernsthaft, man kann doch eigentlich
Nosha, Kennels, Defense gar nicht verlieren.
Es sei denn, man hat einen guten Helipilot
als Gegner, was durchaus
sein kann.
Also ein guter Helipilot ist halt...
Weil wenn du den ersten Ansturm bei Nosha,
Kennels abgeblockt hast, du kannst die Runde
eigentlich nicht mehr verlieren,
weil die Attackerboote nicht richtig spawnen.
Das ist halt auch ziemlich, ziemlich,
ziemlich broken, wenn man sich das mal überlegt.
Und die kriegen es halt nicht hin.
Ich meine, ich will es mal nicht ausschli... Oh.
Oder die haben das heute tatsächlich
gefixt. Okay, alles klar.
Ich meine, wir wollen ja mal
Dice jetzt hier nicht irgendwie schlechter reden,
als sie sind, wobei das kann ja zu...
Ehrlich gesagt ist es schwierig, Dice schlechter
zu reden, als sie sind.
Wie macht man, was macht man eigentlich gegen so
Schilddudes?
Höchstes Schießen ist ja nicht.
Hä?
Was macht man gegen so Schilddudes? Ich glaube gar nichts.
Einfach sterben.
Sag mal, wo sind...
Ich hab da mal
eine Frage. Chatge.
Wo, wo, wo, wo sind
meine Teammates?
Wo sind meine... Die müssen doch hier irgendwo sein.
Die spielen
Battlebit. Okay, möglich, möglich.
Aber die Runde ist voll, also...
Fake News, Chat. Oh.
Auto. Ich, ich mach mal
ganz Mr. Objective
mach ich. Mr., Mr., Mr. Objective.
Hehehe.
Alter. Mr. Objective.
Mr. Objective geht einmal weg.
Ich hör den.
Oh, shit.
Alter, der
Schilddude, man. Teammates wurden
rausgepatcht. Ja, sieht fast so aus.
Richtig gebashed hat er mich.
Ja. In your face,
sozusagen.
Ich mach mal hier ne Runde.
Ne Runde Legehenne.
Legehennen am Start.
Okay, 50, 50.
Alles.
Oh, guck mal da. Da sind sie.
Wir sollten, wir sollten
auf jeden Fall nicht
nicht in Sicht vom LLV stehen.
Das ist ziemlich
Rehat-Time.
Pass mal auf, wir warten jetzt hier...
Ja, Kollege, das hast
dir, das hast dir,
das hast dir so gedacht, oder?
Also die denken, die denken glaube ich auch
absolut,
completely pipega.
Oh, ich glaub da ist noch einer drin, oder?
Oh, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne.
Wir probieren mal was.
Kann sein, dass ich gleich dead bin.
Möglich, dass ich gleich dead bin.
Aber ich will mal kurz hier runter gucken.
Aber hier ist nichts mehr. Okay, ich bin dead.
Dead.
Und nix wie weg hier.
Oh, shit.
Shit, shit, shit, shit.
Wie, wie haben die gearmt?
Leute,
wie, wie, ach das, die haben nicht B gearmt.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, shit.
Ich muss, ich muss B defenden.
Nein, ich bin dead.
Ja, gut. Leute, mehr kann ich nicht
machen. An mir links
nicht. Okay,
die fahren an B ran. A ist eh lost.
A ist lost. Richtig lost, gell?
Achtung, Achtung,
ich muss ran, die sind schon dran.
What the hell?
Ist das durch den durchgeflogen?
Naja, ich war ein bisschen lahm, aber
das war das Einzige, was ich machen konnte.
Ne, Teammates,
Teammates sind, gibt's nicht.
Outdated, overrated,
jebaited.
Würde ich sagen.
Aber,
naja doch, jetzt haben sie sogar.
Mein Gott,
Alter, die sind aber hartnäckig.
Pass mal auf, lege Hände, lege Händen
rein. Oh, shit.
Shit, shit, shit, shit.
Alter, alter.
Okay, nice ist
nichts, äh,
nicht pro-Aim.
Noch nett ausgedrückt.
Alter, wo ist, wo ist Spawn?
Netter Spawn, dankeschön, dankeschön,
Game. Oh, shit.
Ich dachte
eigentlich, die trifft mich nicht, wenn sie da oben
liegt. Da hätte ich von hinten
einfach drei Leute killen können noch.
Aber, nein.
Ja, das war blöd. Hätte ich eigentlich wissen müssen.
Ja, ey, ich dachte es geht, wenn ich da
liege, ja.
Alter, ran da, ran da.
Jawoll.
Diffuse Gear, no.
Der dreckige Dan
hat mich überholt.
Alter, wie haben wir das denn verloren,
ne? Die haben noch nicht mal,
die haben noch nicht mal einen Heli-Typ am Start.
Also, ernsthaft,
du kannst das eigentlich gar nicht
wirklich verlieren, wenn nicht ein guter Heli-Pilot am Start
ist. Also, normalerweise ist das ziemlich
schwierig. Ja,
weiß echt nicht, was...
Die kommen doch bestimmt von links
angerückt, ja.
Ich höre
da schon was.
Wenn ich Pech habe, war da halt noch einer.
Ich bin mir da jetzt... Okay, Leute,
ich gehe unten rum. Ich gehe unten rum und
guck mal. Pass mal auf, wir stelzen
uns durch den Rauch und hoffen, dass da nichts ist.
Oh, ich höre da oben was
rennen.
Ich komme nicht hoch.
So.
Oh, Alter,
Panzer-Dude.
Willst du wirklich hier lang?
Nee, oder? Nee, nee, nee, willst du
nicht. Wollte ich grad sagen.
Warum willst du da ausgerechnet
lang fahren, wo ich bin?
Okay, nice.
Der wusste, dass ich da bin.
Nice. Sehr gut, Max.
Beste aller Zeiten, ja.
Oh.
Oh, Alter, was geht mit dem ab?
Shit.
Tarifverhandlungen
bei der Bahn gescheitert.
Warum das denn? Heute
Morgen haben es noch erzählt,
die Tarifverhandlungen, also,
nee, was haben sie heute Morgen erzählt in den Nachrichten?
Weitere Streiks so gut
wie abgewendet. Tarifverhandlungen
laufen irgendwie
exzellent. Alter, ich bin so schlecht.
Leute, ich muss
mal kurz mich ein bisschen konzentrieren auf das Game.
Das ist eine Mischung aus PPGAIM
und Chatlesen.
Wir verlieren ernsthaft.
Und, ich mein, es ist ein Meckern
auf hohem Niveau, ja. Ich mein, an mir wird's
nicht schein, aber wir verlieren ernsthaft
Loscher-Kennels-Defense, ohne dass
die ordentlich einen Helipilot haben.
Was? Die Tarifverhandlungen sind gescheitert.
Teilt ihr die Eisenbahn?
Oh, geil. Oh, oh.
Du machst das schon hier. Ich hau ab.
Oh, nee, Alter. Da hab ich ja
überhaupt keinen Bock drauf.
Da hab ich ja überhaupt keinen Bock drauf,
dass die, dass die
jetzt wieder streik
und, oh, das, also
die Panzertypen sind schon, sind tatnäckig.
Okay, der ist dead.
Also, ganz ehrlich,
da hab ich wirklich keinen Bock drauf.
Die haben mich gestern schon wieder so aufgeregt.
Müsst ihr euch vorstellen, ich hab gestern
anstatt, anstatt 20 Minuten
45 Minuten gebraucht.
Klar, kann jetzt einer sagen,
45 Minuten ist doch eigentlich vollkommen im Rahmen.
Überhaupt kein... Ah, shit.
Verkackt. Na, das find ich gut.
Wenn man selbst dran schuld ist, weil man PP-Guard hat,
dann ist das ja kein Ding.
Oh, shit.
Boah, was ist denn hier los?
Ja, also, serious, Leute.
Dachstelz wird unser M-Com nicht retten.
Ich sag ja nur, ne?
Fährst du eigentlich
einen Tesla? Nee.
Ich hab zwar ein Elektroauto, aber ich hab keinen
Tesla.
Wenn du es wissen willst...
Sterben, please.
Oh, nee, die machen Legehenne.
Ich mach jetzt einfach
defuse, gell? In der Hoffnung, es passiert mir nichts.
Nein, nein! Oh, Gott.
Da macht... Da covert auch keiner, ne?
Keiner macht mal einen Smoke
oder irgendwas.
Das ist 404, team not found.
Nice.
Also, ach, see,
ich weiß nicht, ob ich schon gesagt hab. Ich fahr einen
500E.
Ähm, als Elektroauto.
Der ist
nicht so groß wie ein Tesla,
aber der kostet nur ein Drittel
von einem Tesla.
Oh, shit.
Gamepad, danke für den Sub.
So, die wollen auf jeden Fall
über die rechte Seite ran.
Pass mal auf hier. Hier, ich seh sie.
Ich hör sie doch schon.
Wir gehen jetzt in den Smoke.
Pass mal auf.
Okay. Seriously?
Shit, shit, shit,
shit, shit, shit, shit.
Shit, Alter. Muss ich alles selber machen
in der Runde, Mann?
Was ist das denn hier? Alter.
Ultra-Hyper-Pepega-Team.
Guckt euch das an.
Der...
Alter.
Was ist mit euch los?
Der dreckige Dan hat halt revived wie Sau, ne?
Der hat schon gerissen.
What the fuck? Was ist mit denen los?
Geht zwar um Java,
aber ich frage trotzdem, kennst du zufällig ein Tool,
mit dem man die deployed Container im Cluster
scannen und Java-Versionen...
Ach so, nee.
Da fällt mir sicher ein...
Moment, Moment, Moment.
Willst du wirklich
deployede Container,
willst du die Container scannen,
oder willst du die deployeden Sachen
scannen?
Also hast du Zugriff auf den Source-Code
und die Build-Files und alles.
Da gibt's Renovate
zum Beispiel, das ist extrem nice.
Wenn du die...
Wenn du quasi
laufende Container
auf Sicherheitslücken scannen willst,
da gibt's
bestimmt Tools, aber fällt mir so aus dem Stehgreif
keins ein. Also wenn du ein gutes
Tool haben willst, um beispielsweise deine Abhängigkeiten
in den Griff zu kriegen, dass du die immer schön
updatest, dann nimm das da.
Nimm das hier.
Das ist wirklich nice. Renovate-Bot.
Gibt's da an der Seite.
So, das funktioniert
folgendermaßen. Ich kann dir das sogar mal zeigen.
Ich glaube, wir haben sogar...
Ich glaube, ich hab das sogar mal...
Was? Warum findet der FiveHeader nicht
auf GitHub?
FiveHeader ist die wichtigste Orga überhaupt
auf GitHub. Hier, FiveHeader.
So, und dann haben wir hier CuteApp.
Und ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob wir da die...
Nee, haben wir nicht.
Zumindest, wenn du...
Ich bin mir
nicht sicher. Ich hatte
irgendwo ein Beispiel, wo man das sieht.
Nee.
Zumindest kannst du dir die Seite angucken.
Der scannt deine ganzen
Config-Files um bereits
laufende Container. Boah, da gibt's...
Oh, guck mal!
Pepega36 unlocked. Nice.
Caspian Border.
Ich weiß nicht, die fund's
in Battlefield 2042 irgendwie nicht richtig.
Ich check mal kurz,
ob wir Attacker sind. Wenn wir Attacker sind,
probier ich's nochmal aus.
Aber noch eine Runde Defense hab ich keinen Bock.
Dann unlock ich erst mal schnell im Bot-Modus
für 5 Minuten ein paar Attachments
für die andere Waffe.
Geht ja schnell. Ich find's übrigens
total beknackt, dass das...
ähm...
dass es gegen Bots geht.
Weil entweder macht man sowas
rein und sagt, hey,
unlock. Dann sollte es auch nur gegen
echte Spieler gehen. Oder man kann's
einfach gleich lassen und für alle unlocken.
Das ist ja auch eine Variante.
Ähm...
Sind wir Attacker? Oh, wir sind Attacker.
Nice. Moin.
Was für Rückblicke in deine beste Konsole
in der Xbox 360 Zeit?
Da gibt es 2 oder Heap ist am Start.
Den hatte ich vorhin angeschrieben, ob er mitmachen will.
Weiß ich nicht,
ob er's gesehen hat.
Ja, hat er nicht.
Komm, ich flieg mal im Heli mit.
Bam, bam, bam.
Haben die 2042 jetzt auch einfach...
Alter!
Die Noobs fliegen den Heli.
Die Noobs fliegen
den Heli, Leute.
Sieht aus wie ein UMP. Sicher, dass das
eine G36 ist? Sieht aus wie
ein UMP an der Stelle.
Alter, das Ding kannst du ja
wieder nicht spielen ohne Aufsatz.
21 Schuss. Die Waffen in Default-Ausführung
sind in diesem Spiel so gottenschlecht,
Alter. Okay, wir probieren
jetzt mal was.
Wir haben eine Waffe, auf der wir nix sehen und so gut
wie... Alles klar, Game.
So, wahrscheinlich snipet
uns der Panzer schon raus. Da drüben stehen sie schon.
Ah, guck mal da. Was ist denn das da?
Oh, da steht der andere Pantsman.
Wir sind gleich One-Shot.
Einfach. Keckel.
Wo?
Wo kam der jetzt?
Sag mal, war der die ganze Zeit
im Busch?
Machst du halt ein nices Play und dann steht
halt so ein Typ im Busch und wartet einfach
nur. Denkst du, hast du alles gekillt? Nee, hast du nicht.
Da steht ein Typ im Busch.
Der war abkacken. Ja, glaub auch.
Der war abkacken.
Lo!
Okay, das ist wie eine Runde Rush, wo unser Team keine Lust
hat zu rushen, vermutlich.
Also so wie gefühlt
90% der Runden, wenn man
wenn man keine, wenn man nicht mindestens
1-2 Premade Leute dabei hat.
Oh oh.
Viel zu offen. Viel zu offen.
Pass auf, ich mach das jetzt
wie der Typ. So.
Ich lenk mich jetzt einfach auch in den Busch und warte, bis einer
vorbeikommt. Easy.
Hä? Guck da!
Busch. Busch-Stelz.
Absolut komplett.
Komplett OP.
Einfach, einfach im Busch rumliegen.
Da kommt
gleich einer raus.
Ich bin 3D-spottet. Da steigt gleich
einer aus und killt mich. Kann ich nichts gegen machen.
Ist der tot, der Panzer?
Oh, nice.
Okay.
Ist der gerade am Fall-Damage gestorben?
Okay, der Pantsman
ist am Start. Das ist...
Leute, ihr könnt sterben.
Ihr könnt sterben und bei mir spawnen.
Das ist besser, als da, wo ihr gerade
rumeiert. Okay.
Au, au, au, au. Okay, nice.
Dead kill.
Zwei Tage PopOS und ich will nicht mehr Windows
0.2, ich kein Teil. Ja, das verstehe ich.
Tiling Window Manager ist einfach das geilste.
Tiling Window Manager
ist das beste überhaupt.
Was benutzt du für ein Tiling Window Manager?
Tommi, benutzt du I3?
Ich finde ja geil,
dass diese Overlays auf der Map so sind, dass man
nichts sieht.
Jetzt steht er einfach hinter mir und schießt nicht.
Ich dachte, wisst ihr,
ich habe was hinter mir gehört, aber es schießt nicht.
Ja, muss ein Teammate sein. Das ist aber
kein Teammate. Okay, lege
Hände. Du hast praktische
Prüfung in was? Ich kann gerade nicht
in den Chat gucken. Ich habe es nur so aus dem Auge gesehen.
Au.
Oh, was ist hier?
Ah, shit.
Oh, nein.
Ich habe mich so verguckt, Alter.
Ich dachte, ich habe die Waffe in der Hand.
Oh, was ist denn hier los?
Shit, aber
wir haben es. Nice.
Kriege.
Leute, Modcheck
Team, Modcheck Team.
Wo sind wir hier?
Und wo...
Alter, wo hovert denn der Dude rum, Mann?
Moment.
Hä? Die Map-Anzeige
ist falsch. Der ist direkt über A.
Bei mir war der sonst wo.
Okay.
So geht es schon mal nicht.
Die Map-Anzeige ist einfach
komplett pipega.
Wann muss man denn drücken, wenn man
nicht zu weit oben
rauskommen will?
Jetzt? Ne, ist auch
ein bisschen zu spät.
Das probieren wir jetzt aus.
So, ein bisschen früher muss man
drücken.
Jetzt?
Ja, das war zu früh. Jetzt bin ich dead.
Ne, das
klappt so nicht.
Ich glaube, wir müssen das anders machen. Wir können hier
rein spawnen, aber
wir springen auf die
andere Seite.
Wir gehen hier hin.
So leicht irgendwie in die Richtung. So, jetzt aber.
Okay, das ist gut.
Alter, fucking...
Ach, Tickets.
Es rusht doch eh keiner.
Oh, shit.
Nice.
Schnell, schnell, schnell, schnell.
Okay, ich rushe...
Da sind Leute hinter mir. Ich rushe da jetzt
aber einfach hin.
Okay.
Nice. Hoffentlich sterbe ich nicht.
Okay, nice.
Gut, wir haben es.
Cool. Hätte ich nicht gedacht.
Das hätte ich nicht gedacht.
Dass wir das
kriegen. Okay, ich...
Leute, ich switche mal schnell
auf eine gescheite Waffe, wo ich was unlockt habe
für. Weil
das ist mir dann doch gerade
nichts.
Volle Pulle. Let's go.
Die haben
auch irgendwann mal den Grappling Hook Range.
Verkürzt.
Moment. Lege Henne.
Wie schnell
waren wir bitteschön an B?
Ich bin gerade aus der Base gerannt.
Wie zum
Teufel waren wir so schnell? Ach, mit dem Heli.
Okay, was anderes.
Ja, das ist ja auch schon ein bisschen doof,
dass das geht, ja.
Aber auf der anderen Seite...
Also, wenn die Gegner nicht total bescheuert sind, ist das halt
einfach mal verschenkte Tickets, weil
so einer überlebt es halt nicht.
Ja, ist gut, Game. Lass mich mal in Ruhe.
Oh.
In meine Richtung gucken zwei Tanks. Nice, Game.
Okay.
Den Bobber ist geschossen.
Ach, shit. Da unten war noch einer.
Äh, vielleicht, vielleicht...
Hab ich Glück. Das ist ein Medic.
Huge res.
Okay, sind wir mal...
Sind wir mal zackig.
Okay, wir sind fast dran.
Shit, shit, shit, shit, shit, shit, shit.
Muss mal kurz...
Okay.
Der ist doch rechts hier, der Typ, oder?
Hier irgendwo.
Wusste ich doch.
Okay, mal gucken, mal gucken, mal gucken,
mal gucken.
Genau da wollte ich hin.
Ich lass den, der weiß nicht, dass ich da bin.
Pass mal auf.
Pass mal auf. Und jetzt, jetzt diffuse da gleich.
Diffuse skill. Und wenn er ran diffuse skill
geht,
dann... Oh, ne, ne.
Ne, der ist, der ist dead, der ist dead.
Wollen wir den diffuse? Doch.
Warum konnte ich mich nicht bewegen?
Ach, wegen der scheiß Konsole.
Ich wundere mich die ganze Zeit.
Alter, warum kann ich nicht woofen?
Okay, wenn wir schon
grad dabei... Oh, nice, ich werd geretzt. Okay.
Nice. TRX.
Leg.
Retz. Retz.
Zackig. Bevor uns der Panzer in den Bobbers
schießt.
Okay.
Perf... Moment, Moment.
Perf, Overlay, Draw,
FPS, 1.
Ja, nice.
Da ist, da ist
doch einer hier.
Bobbers, Bobbers geschossen.
Ähm.
Was ist mit den Dudes da los?
Sind die AFK? Okay.
Ich weiß, dass ich da...
Oh, shit, Alter. Ich weiß, dass ich da
nicht rüber muss, aber ich hätt's im Leben
nicht übers Feld geschafft.
Hab mir gedacht, vielleicht, vielleicht
hat man mal ein bisschen Flank-Action machen können.
Okay. Ich weiß nicht genau, woran du
gestorben bist, aber ich... Okay, YOLO.
Wir versuchen... Da... Oh,
shit, Panzer.
Pants, man.
Der...
Nun gut.
Vielleicht hab ich Glück. Da kommt ein...
Oh, oh, oh, Legehenne, Legehenne. Nice.
Schnell rein, schnell rein. Wir sollten noch genug Tickets haben, glaube ich.
Wie viele, wie viele Tickets haben wir noch?
Ähm.
Au. Oh Gott, fuck it, Alter.
Da krieg... Aber hier krieg ich jetzt
ein Räts. Come on.
Äh, wir haben Tickets 52.
Ja, das müsste...
Das müsste gehen.
Schauen wir mal, ob das...
Alter, da ist ja immer noch der Panzer da.
Jetzt.
Meine Güte.
Der ist aber echt hartnäckig.
Der Panzer.
Oh, links, links, links, links.
Nice.
Jetzt, jetzt wird's aber langsam anstrengend.
Haben wir vielleicht irgendeinen, der
Rätzen kann?
Medic, Medic? Nee, haben wir nicht.
Ich geh mal neu rein.
Oh, wir sind ja richtig am Arsch.
Pass mal auf, Legacy Feature. Wir benutzen jetzt das
krasseste Legacy Feature überhaupt.
Wir gehen jetzt in das Morgendämmerer Squad.
Und? Gute Idee schon.
Gute Idee gewesen.
Morgendämmerer Squad. Siehste?
Richtige High IQ Dudes am Start.
Mit guten Spot Points.
Ich bin mir nicht so ganz schlüssig, wo die Feinde
sind, aber okay.
Sag mal, what the hell?
Die Schütze sind einfach durchgeflogen wieder.
Lul.
Okay, ich muss mal die Posi wechseln.
Das wird mir zu anstrengend.
Gerade.
Oh, was ist denn hier los?
Was ist denn hier los? Was ist da?
Was ist da?
Ich hätte einst gedacht, da ist was.
Jetzt könnt ihr bei mir rein spawnen,
wenn ihr wollt.
Aber will, glaube ich, keiner.
Oh, ich höre was unter mir.
Wir haben nur noch 26.
Okay, jetzt müssen wir...
Jetzt müssen wir ran.
Die wissen, dass wir da sind.
Jetzt müssen wir ran. Wir haben nicht mal viel.
Aber wir können nicht. Sobald wir über die Straße gehen, sind wir dead.
Massive dead.
Um nicht zu sagen, dead ge...
Okay.
Wir probieren mal was.
Jawoll, jawoll, jawoll.
Jetzt rennen sie alle da hin
und wir können von hinten in Bobbes.
Jawoll, so ist gut.
Kommen gleich noch mehr.
What? Was ist das, Game?
Was ist hier los?
Game!
Ich weiß nicht mal von wo.
Oh, wir haben es, glaube ich.
Haben wir es? Haben wir es? Jawoll!
Jawoll, nice.
Wir verlieren, Leute.
Ich habe nicht gecheckt,
beziehungsweise ich habe nicht realisiert,
dass das eigentlich schon off...
Also...
So, sie verlassen...
Sie verlassen die...
Das Schlachfeld
hier ist.
Oh, oh, oh.
Wow!
Da war ja noch einer.
Hab ich eigentlich... Eigentlich hab ich den gesehen.
Wenn ich mal...
Der ist gerätst. Das ist schlecht.
Wir sind jetzt dead gleich.
Der hat noch mehr PP geaimt
als ich. Anders ist es nicht
zu erklären.
Ragman sagt, war kurz drin, war unspielbar.
Wieso? Was hast du für eine Map gekriegt?
Hat der Heap eigentlich geantwortet?
Nope.
Na gut, dann...
Okay, ich vermute... Leute, ich vermute, es geht nicht um Battlefield.
Wenn ich FaceIt höre,
dann denke ich an alles, nur nicht an Battlefield.
Eigentlich fällt mir
mit FaceIt kein anderes Game als CS ein,
wenn ich ehrlich bin.
Hat FaceIt noch was anderes als...
CS?
Also, es gibt einen FaceIt-Anti-Cheat-Client,
den hatte Battle...
Battlebit.
Oh ne, dachte ich bin außer.
So viele! Hier sind 30 Milliarden Leute.
Valorant
ist wild.
Ich dachte, Valorant ist dead.
Jetzt, wo CS rauskommt.
Haha,
das war zu viel.
Oh nein, ich habe releast, ich dachte, wir sind dead.
Okay, YOLO-Style.
Achtung, Achtung.
Also, wenn ich hier durchkomme... Nein.
Ich habe gedacht, komm, ein Versuch.
Leute,
ernsthaft. Alter, warum...
Wie kann...
Ich meine, ihr seht mich. Es ist nicht,
dass ich in irgendeiner Art und Weise
schon hier am Optimum spielen würde, ja?
Aber,
ganz ehrlich, ich frage mich, was die Leute so
treiben, wenn der alte Sack
mit fast 39 und dem
übelsten PP-Geheim auf Doom
Erster ist und mit doppelt so vielen Kills
wieder Zweiter.
Ja, ich habe bald Geburtstag.
Das hast du gut erkannt, ja.
Okay, das war nix.
Ist nicht mehr lange hin.
Dauert noch, dauert noch so...
Ja.
Doch, doch. Ein paar Wochen dauert das schon noch.
Okay, pass mal auf.
Wir holen jetzt... Wir gehen jetzt hier durch den Smog.
Wir machen hier noch einen Smog, weil der hat uns gesehen.
Ich warte eigentlich nur noch auf meinen Enter-Haken.
Ja.
Oh, oh.
Bobbesgeschoßen.
Gachi-Time.
Unter mir sind welche.
Jetzt müssen wir sich mal auf
ein Target konzentrieren können.
Okay, die können ja nur von hier kommen.
Oh shit, da links war noch einer.
Da war noch einer.
Jetzt ist aber gerade schon
so ein bisschen wie auf dem Sportplatz.
So.
Was in deinem Team heißt einer Gurken
aus dem Glas? Zeig mal.
Oh, der ist richtig gut. Der hat's
gerissen, würde ich sagen.
Besser als Eggplant aus dem Glas.
Eats. Es ist immer...
Ihr wisst wie das ist? Ne, das war nicht easy.
Die Runde war nicht easy.
Es ist immer easy,
umso knapper es ist.
Also ich glaube, ihr habt diese grundlegende Gaming-
Logik noch nicht verstanden.
Wenn die Runde wirklich einfach war,
dann ist das einfach kein Kommentarwert.
Wenn die Runde
knapp as fuck war, ist es easy.
Und umso knapper das ist.
Also es geht von knapp zu einfach quasi
zu einem Frame knapp.
Und wenn das so knapp ist, wie es nur sein kann,
dann ist es das easiest game of my life
oder sowas gewesen.
Also es ist erst richtig easy,
wenn es eigentlich schwer ist.
Das ist die Gaming-Logik
quasi dahinter.
Wisst ihr, was mir gerade auffällt?
In dem Battle Pass ist schlicht und ergreifend nichts drin, was man haben will.
Wie kriegen die überhaupt 100 Level voll?
Lasst uns das mal kurz checken.
Battle Pass. Was kriegen wir denn hier für tolle Sachen?
Okay. Wir kriegen den XP-Boost.
Das ist eigentlich ganz gut.
Äh, was jetzt?
Ne, komm. Come on.
Und Defender. Ne, ne, ne.
So viel Border spielen wir jetzt nicht.
Nicht, dass ich was gegen die Map hab.
Aber man kann es ja irgendwann auch mal übertreiben.
Wie ging nochmal?
Freunde-Invite.
Rush-Spieler. Rush.
Kann man ihm joinen?
Nice. Okay, das ist irgendein
Six-Head-Private-Match.
Das ist nur für coole Leute.
Da kann ich nicht mitmachen.
Ja, richtig.
Du hast es erkannt.
Also ich hoffe, du bist auch wirklich
nur um Haaresbreite an dem Baum vorbeigekommen.
Dann war das easy.
Jetzt hat er es verstanden.
Genau so ist das.
Also, wenn man
besonders easy Sachen machen will,
dann müssen sie in Wirklichkeit besonders knapp sein.
Was kommt als nächstes?
Rush-Exposure.
Aber Defense.
Attack hätte ich Bock gehabt.
Mal wieder drauf.
Wisst ihr, das Blöde ist halt,
dass das Legacy-Feature immer noch nicht richtig implementiert ist.
Ja, genau.
Dass es immer noch nicht so richtig implementiert ist,
dass man nicht nur
Squads wechseln kann,
sondern auch,
Leute, einfach Seiten
wechseln kann. Wäre das nicht
cool, wenn jemand
sagt, ey, ich hab keinen Bock
an, ne, ich könnte mal eine andere Waffe spielen.
Ich hab jetzt echt keinen Bock auf noch eine Runde
Defense und es ist noch Platz
im Attacker-Team, dass du rüberspielst.
Du nimmst ja keinen Platz weg, wenn noch Platz ist.
Dann switchst du einfach
ins Attacker-Team rüber und kannst das
spielen, worauf du Bock hast.
Also, das geht nicht, oder?
Ich glaube, das ist eindeutig
Way to Legacy,
dass man einfach das spielen kann.
Game, ja.
Dass man einfach
das spielen kann, worauf man Bock hat.
Wow, what the fuck?
Moment, ich muss mal kurz hier raus.
Wow, fast PP-Guard,
Leute. Passt.
Fast Henshin PP-Guard.
Och nee, come on.
Wow!
Hahaha.
Kick!
Oh nein!
Das war der Defuse des Jahrhunderts.
Okay, den Shotgun wär jetzt.
Okay, nein, den Shotgun wär doch nicht.
Ich verpiss mich jetzt einfach
mal ganz schnell.
Aber da müsst ihr sagen, es war ein gutes Play, auch wenn
es nicht so geplant war.
Es war wirklich nicht so geplant.
Es war echt nicht so geplant.
Ich wollte den Typen nicht
mit dem Grappling-Hook anschießen,
sondern ich wollte eigentlich auf meine
Shotgun switchen.
Okay, jetzt drücken sie von der Seite.
Ich muss aufs Dach, Leute. Ich muss aufs Dach,
in der Hoffnung, dass nicht 20 Gegner vor mir stehen.
Ich muss aufs Dach und alles
wegschnetzeln, was vom Dach rüberkommt.
Oder beziehungsweise...
Okay. Oh, oh, oh!
Achtung, Reload fast, Reload fast.
Kopf raus! Kopf raus!
Kopf raus! Let's go!
Kopf raus!
Alter!
Was ist hier los?
Warum nicht Kopf raus?
Hinter mir? Hinter mir? Hinter mir? Hinter mir?
Hä? Ah, nee, Teammate.
Aber hier, hier ist doch jetzt...
Ich hör doch da!
Ich hör doch da 30.000 Gegner laufen grad.
Hä?
What? Hä?
Habt ihr das...
Habt ihr das nicht auch gehört?
Da waren grad 5 Gegner oder so Schritte, Steps.
Oder ist das Boomer-Ohr?
Habt ihr das auch gehört?
Oder ist mein Ohr einfach auch schon 39
und hört Mist?
Ja, ich glaub, da ist wirklich nix.
Oh! Oh!
Oh!
Ja, okay.
It's released da auch noch.
Man kann es ja mal probieren.
Okay.
Von wo kommen sie? Von wo kommen sie?
Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein.
Lasst mal eure komischen Granaten weg.
Das mag ich mal gar nicht.
Oh, shit, Alter!
Das waren ein bisschen viele.
Aber da sollte genug zum Respawn stehen von mir.
Das können wir halten.
Also eigentlich müssen wir das easy defenden.
Ich bleib mal nah drin.
Ey, ich bleib nicht mehr nah drin.
Das ist zu langweilig.
Ich geh noch mal aufs Dach.
Oh, Alter, was ist denn?
Was ist in dem Turm los?
Ich baller da einfach mal rein.
Ich seh zwar nix.
Oh, PP got time, PP got time.
Oh, der legt!
Lege Henne!
Shit! Den hätt ich haben müssen.
Dann hätten wir es defusen können.
Team, ihr dürft euch umdrehen.
Team, dreht euch um.
Killt die Gegner, Mann.
Und defuse den Kram.
Ihr seid 20 Leute an dem M-Com, Alter.
Okay.
Das war...
Leute, war das easy oder nicht?
Bin mir nicht ganz sicher.
Das war eigentlich nicht knapp genug für easy.
Das war noch erste Base.
Ich glaube, das war nicht easy.
Nee, nee. Definitiv nicht easy.
Du störst mich nicht.
Ich streame den Kram, dass man mich stört.
Ich will dich echt nicht beim Game stören.
Vielleicht kann das der Chat auch mal.
Aber wenn man vom Software-Skalieren spricht,
meint man damit nur das Backend,
wenn man nicht skaliert.
Ja, würde ich auch so sagen.
Also, in der Regel
ist Software-Skalieren
ein sehr schwammiger Begriff.
Man müsste etwas genauer spezifizieren,
was man eigentlich skalieren möchte.
Requests,
User, keine Ahnung.
Du kannst ja prinzipiell
alles mögliche skalieren.
Aber das Frontend juckt dich in der Regel nicht.
Das hast du richtig erkannt. Das Frontend ist egal.
Das Frontend ist sozusagen
schon von Haus aus skaliert.
Weil,
naja, du hast halt einmal das Frontend
pro Client, wenn es eine Web-Anwendung ist.
Oder vielleicht sogar, wenn du den Tab
mehrfach auf hast, mehrfach das Frontend pro Client.
Also Frontend musst du
in der Regel nicht skalieren.
Es geht hauptsächlich um die Backend-Anwendung,
wenn es um das Thema Skalierung geht.
Und da gibt es natürlich verschiedene Varianten,
an welcher Stelle du vielleicht was skalieren musst.
Ist es eher was Richtung
Bandbreite? Ist es Request pro Sekunde?
Ist es vielleicht,
dass du musst gucken, wo du dein
Bottleneck, ist es die Verbindung zur Datenbank?
Also reicht es dir, wenn du deine
Backend-Anwendung skalierst,
hast du mehr Reads als Writes
bei der Datenbank, was relativ wahrscheinlich ist.
Also reicht dir vielleicht ein Datenbank-Cluster
mit, sagen wir mal, irgendwie 3 Knoten.
Einer ist nur Master, der schreiben darf.
Der andere kann nur lesen.
Aber dafür parallel,
also das statische HTML ausliefern ist
jetzt in der Regel nichts, was
einem beim Skalieren
großartige Kopfschmerzen bereitet, weil
das funktioniert ja ohne
großartigen State und außerdem der neue Trend,
was Frontend-Ausliefern angeht,
ist ja Edge-Computing, nee,
wie nennt sich das?
Doch Edge-Computing, oder?
Nochmal! Wollt ihr mich verarschen?
Ich soll die Map nochmal
spielen. Exakt gleiche Map, exakt.
Ja.
Also der Trend ist ja, geht ja
aktuell ein bisschen hin zu CDN,
nicht CDN. Ja, ich glaub, Edge-Computing
nennt man das. Also, nee, nicht Quatsch, was
laber ich? Edge-Computing, da geht auch
der Trend hin, aber
quasi, dass du die
Software auslieferst, nicht von deinem
Server, sondern von irgendeinem CDN
beziehungsweise auch schon teilweise
das ganze vorrenderst. Was mach ich denn
hier eigentlich? Total bescheuert.
Die Seite auch schon vorrenderst,
hier ist nix, okay,
schon vorrenderst
per Edge-Computing,
dass die Seite beim initialen Aufrufen
schnell lädt.
Was willst du denn skalieren?
Ich hab keinen Bock auf nochmal die Map.
Wenn wir die erste Base verlieren und es
schnell over ist, dann...
What? What the fuck?
Warum hat der so viel ausgehalten?
Whatever.
Ich muss mal kurz vom Dach runter.
Hier ist ne gute Pose.
Sag mal, Game,
kann das mal hitten, please?
Okay, jetzt reicht's.
Jetzt reicht's, YOLO!
Wo ist er?
Hahahaha!
Oh shit,
jetzt hab ich ihn hingeguckt.
Der Typ mit dem Messer, der war geil eben, oder?
Okay, please, nicht sterben.
Nein! Okay,
dead kill. Eyes lost.
Okay, vielleicht,
vielleicht kann ich von hinten noch...
Pass mal auf.
Vielleicht, vielleicht komm ich da noch hin.
Nein.
Richtig gemacht, die haben durchs Fenster geguckt.
Die meisten gucken nicht durchs Fenster,
wenn man von da hinten angestellt kommt.
Okay, jetzt, also,
ich glaube nicht, dass wir A noch defended kriegen.
Wir sollten eher
alle unsere Sachen auf B werfen,
weil die jetzt hier ranpushen werden.
Was ist denn hier los?
Lege Henne, defuse, defuse kill,
defuse kill.
Ey, schieb mich doch nicht weg, bist du dumm?
Alter, warum schiebt der mich
im M-Combat? What the fuck?
Oh, shit. Shit, hab ich nicht gesehen.
No!
Nicht dead kill gehen,
nicht dead kill gehen, please, nicht dead kill.
Lass mich spawnen.
No! Okay, dann geh ich bei dem ran.
Alter! Nein.
Game, please, please.
Game, lass mich, lass mich spawnen.
No.
Okay, nein.
Ich hab keinen Bock mehr auf Defense
auf der Map. Hab gesagt, wenn wir die erste Base
verlieren, sorg ich neu.
So.
Und nachdem,
lass uns mal kurz die Unlocks angucken von der
neuen Waffe.
War eine allgemeine Frage, da man öfters
von skalieren spricht,
was ich aber nicht verstanden habe.
Ja, nee, beim Frontend,
das hast du richtig verstanden.
Frontend wird in der Regel nicht groß
skaliert.
Hier, was haben wir denn da für Unlocks? Was gibt's denn da?
Okay, wenigstens
schon mal ein gescheites...
Okay.
Also eigentlich interessieren mich hauptsächlich die Magazine.
Wann gibt's denn das erste 30
Schuss Magazin? Okay,
20 Kills noch, das machen wir jetzt schnell.
Das ist ja kein Ding.
Das können wir jetzt schneller machen,
nächste Runde. Rusch, auf geht's, let's go.
Hast du das doppelt gesagt, was?
Möglich.
Manchmal,
wenn ich mich auf zwei Sachen konzentrieren muss,
dann macht das Boomer Brain nicht mal mit.
Achso, ja nee, das habe ich
jetzt nochmal so als Fazit gesagt.
Das hat er richtig verstanden, ja.
Renewal.
Naja.
Da habe ich schon geile Runden gehabt,
oder richtig bodenlose Runden.
KeckW46, Rusch.
Hoffentlich Attacker. Nee.
Natürlich Defense.
Charlie Foxtrot, here we come.
Alles klar. Charlie Foxtrot, was soll
das heißen? CF?
Für was steht CF?
Ist das irgendwie
Six Hand Military Speak, den man als
Normalsterblicher nicht versteht?
Capture the Flag?
Aber wir capturen gar keine Flag.
Auf der anderen Seite, es könnte durchaus
Capture the Flag bedeuten, weil das Game
gibt sich ja eh keine Mühe,
das anzupassen für unterschiedliche
Spielmodi.
Fuck.
Okay, wir gehen mal an B rüber.
Chaotic Situation.
Okay, alles klar.
Ja,
NATO Alphabet ist nicht so meins.
Oh.
Fuck, warum gehen die jetzt auf A?
Normalerweise machen die immer große, große
Runde und gehen auf B,
aber nein, die haben keinen Bock
auf B zu gehen.
Da ist ein Auto.
Und da hinten ist noch ein LAV.
Jetzt wird's blöd.
Oh shit,
das war sehr schlau, Max. Das ist ganz toll.
Mal kurz mit dem Grappling-Hook in die Luft
geschossen. Das hat's absolut
rausgerissen jetzt, die Runde.
Also Leute, ihr wisst, das ist einfach
hier zum Gegner dissen, immer mal eine Runde
in die Luft Grappling hooken.
Erste Base ist aber eh kaum zu defenden.
Hab ich ganz selten gesehen.
Bob ist,
Bob ist geschultet.
Vielleicht krieg ich dich ja noch.
Spritze in den Sack.
Nee, da ist noch einer.
Ja, und dem haben wir jetzt einfach
zwei Kills geschenkt.
Zwei Kills geschenkt.
Oh, guck mal, nice, hier kommt man noch ran.
Ach nee, ih.
Die sind ja
dein PP-Gas. Guckt's euch mal an.
Passt mal auf, damit rechnen die jetzt nicht.
Ey, Alter,
immer diese Leute, die man nicht sieht
in Battlefield,
die dich killen. Immer wirst du von dem gekillt,
den du nicht siehst.
Warum spawnen die eigentlich da unten, Leute?
So.
Oh, shit.
Lul, der hat ge...
Moment, wir haben... Wait a minute.
Wir haben noch nicht
verloren?
Wir haben noch nicht verloren? Okay, auf geht's.
Da geht's rein jetzt hier.
Oh, shit.
Okay, vielleicht, vielleicht krieg ich dich noch.
Na, das war zu viel.
Ja.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Medic!
Tja.
Hätte ich wiedergelebt,
hätten wir die jetzt gebashed.
Okay, wir probieren das jetzt einfach mal aus.
Ich mach jetzt mal
YOLO-Mode. Ich mein, als Defender hast
du eh unendlich Tickets.
Ist also egal.
Aber wir haben keinen...
Okay, zu viel, zu viel, zu viel.
Ach, fuck, wir haben's...
Wir haben's gerade
verloren, jetzt in dem Moment.
Okay.
Äh, nice, ja, okay.
Ja, was willst du machen?
Ich bin halt auf der Karte die ganze Zeit.
Hast du nicht so ein
Bediendings für PowerPoint?
Äh, what?
Oh, komm her.
LOL!
Alter, wie hab ich denn das überlebt?
Crate, crate. Heal, please.
Shit, okay.
Kannste ja noch mal probieren.
Mein...
What?
Wie haben die jetzt gearmt so schnell?
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Oh, oh.
Oh!
Ich hatte Boomer-Hirn überfordert.
Ich hab 50 Gegner um mich gehört
gerade.
Okay, schnell, schnell, schnell hier.
Volle Pulle, volle Pulle.
Gib ihm, gib ihm.
Ich ignore den Typ auf dem Dach.
Jawoll, jawoll.
Gib Gas.
Shit, man. Immer die, die man nicht sieht.
So ist es im Battlefield.
Haben wir 20 Kills gemacht? Nope.
Aber in 4 Kills, in 4 Kills kriegen wir endlich
ein ordentliches Magazin für die Waffe.
Dann kann man die vielleicht sogar spielen.
Ähm...
Okay.
Yolo-Modus.
Alles klar.
Nice. Dankeschön. Dankeschön, Game.
Für den nice Spread
der Assault Rifles.
Au!
Ich muss, ich muss reagieren.
Ich muss reagieren. Ich bin dead.
Wo?
Alter, Dude, wo bist du denn?
Alter, wo rennt denn
der Typ rum?
Ja gut, ich glaube, wir wollen keine M-Comps verteidigen.
M-Comps
is outdated, overrated, shebaited.
Wer spielt schon
Objective?
Alter, das ist viel zu viel hier.
Wer spielt schon Objective?
Ist einfach komplett lächerlich, wer sowas macht.
Anscheinend
zumindest, ne? Also mein...
Richtige Boomer-Taktik, Objective.
Objective-Play. Keckel.
Oh!
Also ich mein, ich probier's ja.
Aber
kannst nur so viel machen, wie du machen kannst.
Ja?
Der ist doch hier irgendwo. Wusste ich doch.
So, gleich haben wir ein
ordentliches Magazin-Unlock, Leute.
Shit!
Von der Seite und
dead. So, also.
Leute, die letzte Base, seriously.
Die letzte Base, die kann man
ganz gut defenden, wenn man will.
Also wenn man will. Ich glaub, ich weiß nicht, ob die wollen.
Die Shotgun ist halt nicht
so geil auf Range, ne?
Man kann's ja mal
ausprobieren. Ich mein,
hey, ohne Scheiß, der Typ hätte
ein Pellet hitten müssen, sonst nix.
Wie jetzt?
Ernsthaft?
Ist
das wirklich so?
Was ist mit der Map los? Warum geht
das nicht auf?
Okay, lost.
Ah, wo geht's denn hier lang?
Wie kommt man hier hoch? Oh, was ist denn da?
Guck mal da. Slide, slide.
Okay, nice.
Oh, oh, oh. Ich muss weg.
Bruder muss los.
Okay, Leute.
Alle an B.
Alle an B. So schwer kann es nicht sein.
Aufs Dach. Guck, da ist schon
einer. Wir gehen jetzt
aufs Dach. Dach ist die beste
Strat hier überhaupt.
Die können B nicht legen, wenn ich
aufm Dach bin.
Guck mal hier.
Guck mal da. Keine Chance.
Keine Chance.
Wow, da war aber Glück, dass ich da gehittet hab.
Nein.
Okay, wisst ihr, was wir jetzt
probieren? Wir gehen da jetzt rüber.
Wir gehen da jetzt rüber.
Ja. Nein, nein, nein.
Du bleibst da mal schön weg.
Ah, du Sack. Warum hast
du mitgekriegt, dass ich da hochkomme?
Kannst du nicht mal Brain AFK spielen, so wie
90% des Spiels spielen und einfach
nicht hingucken, wenn man was macht?
Was ist mit dem los? Warum denkt der mit?
Ich glaube, den müssen wir D-Dossen,
Leute.
Oder?
D-Dos ist raus.
Oh, shit.
Oh, shit. Okay, wir haben verloren.
Ich probier's
noch mal, aber ich glaube, wir sind...
Ich weiß noch nicht mal, wo ich
beschossen werde, aber...
Ja, wir haben's verloren.
Ja, machste nix. Wir brauchen
wieder das Team vom letzten Mal.
Da ging's ab.
Und heute noch
Captain Poggers dabei, falls der online ist.
Mal was trinken.
Übrigens, gucken wir mal, ob ich
irgendwelche Subs übersehen hab, aber ich glaube
nicht.
Gamepad war der letzte. Dankeschön, aber ich glaube,
ihr habt's schon gesehen vorhin.
So, Moment.
Gucke. Unlocks.
Unlocks.
Es muss doch jetzt gescheite Magazinen geben.
Game.
Geh mal ins Hauptmenü.
Cool.
Ah, nein, nein, nein, nein.
Nicht PPK29.
KeckW36.
Ja.
Okay.
Und das dahin.
Und haben wir noch einen Lauf? Nope.
Wallparaiso!
Und Attacker! Jawoll!
Jetzt wird
gebashed.
Beste Map.
Die Map
spielt sich witzigerweise
schlechter als BC2,
weil aus irgendwelchen
Gründen
alle dünnen Holzwände
auf dieser Map nicht
penetrierbar sind.
Warum? Weil Dice wahrscheinlich keinen Bock gehabt hat,
die Map zu patchen.
Und
die Map basiert gerade in dem Dorf
halt schon irgendwie drauf,
dass du die Gegner durch die Gebäude
hitten kannst und dich nicht in einen
Holzmast stellen kannst und halt nicht
treffbar bist.
Wollen wir mal mit dem Typ fliegen?
Komm, wir fliegen mal mit.
Die Noobs fliegen den Heli, Leute.
Ihr dürft Wetten abschließen.
Kommen wir beim M-Command oder nicht?
Oh, oh, oh, oh!
Okay.
Okay, das hat schon mal funktioniert.
Ja, es wäre doch Bock, wenn du ein bisschen
ranfliegen könntest.
Okay, nice.
Oh, da steht...
Und Spritze in Bobbes.
Was ist denn da los?
Habt ihr gesehen? Man kann da nicht durchschießen.
Keine Chance.
Alter. Der Shotgun-Typ!
Nee, Airburst.
Airburst-Typ.
Ah, hier. Nice.
Äh...
Äh... Wo sind wir?
Wo sind wir? Ach, da sind wir.
Okay, nice. Premiere.
Leute, komplett
Premiere. Ich hab in dem Flugzeug
mit dieser Waffe,
legit, side-release,
nichts gekillt.
Mir war gar nicht klar,
dass das überhaupt geht.
Woah!
What the f...
Wo ist hier unten und wo ist oben?
We close.
Oh, shit!
Alter, warum guckst du
in die Richtung?
Anzeige ist raus. Komplett.
Oh, wir haben einen Medic in der Base
gehabt.
Das hätte ich eigentlich nicht gedacht.
Okay, gut.
Extremly POG.
In the Egg!
Keg W
46 OP.
Nö.
Da ist ein Medic.
Medic.
Ich seh nichts mehr.
Nice.
Sterben, please.
Alter, 18-2.
Was ist denn jetzt los?
Chico, ich hab jetzt keine Zeit, mit dir was zu machen.
Ich muss jetzt bashen.
Guck, man kann nichts mehr treffen. Seht ihr das?
Habt ihr gesehen? Du kannst keine Holzplatten mehr durchschießen.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Chico, ich mach jetzt nichts
mit dir. Ich muss bashen.
Das geht jetzt nicht.
Wir rennen jetzt hinter Boris her.
Der soll sein Schild hochmachen. Boris, Schild!
Ne, das ist gar nicht Boris, oder?
Ist das Boris, Leute?
Ne. Ne.
Boris, Boris.
Boris ist der mit der Sentry.
Ich glaub, das ist gar nicht Boris.
Wie heißt denn
der Schild-Dude?
Chico ist jetzt auf dem Schrank
und guckt mich mit dem Arsch an, gerade.
Weil ich mit ihm nichts gemacht hab.
Wie heißt denn der Typ
mit dem Schild?
Ähm, das ist nicht Boris.
Okay, pass auf. Trick 17.
Jawoll.
Die BC-2-Skills regeln.
BC-2-Skills regeln.
Oh, shit.
Oh, close.
Close AF.
Danke, Game, dass du so gut
funktionierst.
So problemfrei und so bugfrei.
Dowser!
Ja, das kann sein, dass das der Typ ist.
Not even close.
Easy war das. Richtig easy.
Wir müssen jetzt mal
das anwenden, was ich vorhin gesagt hab.
Umso knapper es ist, umso mehr easy ist es.
Das war einfach easiest
of my life war das.
Wow.
Der ist doch bestimmt
noch hier drin, oder?
Leute, Waldparaiso.
Einfach geilste Map überhaupt.
So pog.
Warum können die eigentlich keine guten Rush-Maps
mehr machen?
Was ist da los?
Na gut, weil kein Mitarbeiter
mehr da ist, der weiß, wie es funktioniert.
Die haben das einfach
komplett verlernt, wie
man
sein Gameplay motiviert.
System in 39 kann man auch noch, oder fast 39,
kann man auch noch halbwegs
was Gescheites spielen, wenn man das Game kennt.
Ah, Moment!
Das geht hier noch?
Das...
Dem bin ich mir
nicht bewusst
gewesen. Ich befürchte,
es ist nicht gewollt, dass man hier an
diese Posi auf der Map kann.
Predicte
ich jetzt einfach mal
bei diesem Clipping-
Error.
Wir returnen zur Combat Area,
Game. Macht dir mal keine Gedanken.
Wir sind Meister im Return
zur Combat Area.
Okay, wenn wir Glück haben...
Wow, wow, wow.
Wenn wir Glück haben, wird das was.
Ganz schlechte
Idee, Max. Ganz schlechte Idee.
Aus irgendwelchen Gründen
hätte das nicht.
Not sure why.
Okay, YOLO.
What the fuck?
Alter, wo stellst du sie denn?
Ah, Boris!
Nee, nicht
Boris.
Sorry, Chat.
Doser!
Dass ich mal nach 2 Jahren die Specialist-Namen
merken kann, Alter.
Das kann nicht Boris.
Oh, fuck.
Das ist einfach ne Granate.
Leute, das war echt mal
ne richtig spaßige Runde. Ich sag euch doch,
Valparaiso, einfach
beste Map.
33-3, komm.
Da können wir echt den Titel machen.
Ähm...
Alter Boomer und junge Tryhards.
Wobei ich glaube, in dem Game gibt's ja eigentlich
keine richtigen jungen Tryhards,
weil die spielen Warzone und
Apex und Fortnite
und sowas.
Immer wenn ich an Fortnite denke,
die sind noch größere Boomer, also ich glaube,
immer wenn ich an Fortnite denke
und die ganzen 12-jährigen Kinder, die mittlerweile,
weil das Game ja auch schon älter, wahrscheinlich eher 16-jährige Kinder sind,
muss ich immer
an dieses Erlebnis denken
von der Gruppe 12-Jährigen,
die vor dem Südbahnhof,
vor der Straßenbahn
den Loser Dance gemacht haben.
Die sind quasi,
Straßenbahn fährt halt an die Haltestelle,
da sind die halt auf die Schienen,
also auf die Straßenbahnschienen
haben die sich gestellt
und haben dann den Loser Dance
Richtung Fahrer
von der Straßenbahn gemacht.
So richtig ultra
cringe beim Zugucken schon gewesen.
Fortnite ist
sechs Jahre alt.
Ja, das kann man sich nicht vorstellen.
Die 12-jährigen Fortnite-Kinder sind heute
volljährig.
Natürlich ist Fortnite relevant.
Games mit so einem Hype wie Fortnite, die sterben nicht einfach aus.
Die sind vielleicht nicht mehr so
präsent überall an jeder Ecke.
Aber sicherlich, Fortnite hat immer noch massiv
viele Spieler.
Sicherlich, sicherlich mehr
Spieler als Battlefield 2042.
X-Defiant.
Stimmt, Leute, ist nicht jetzt gerade
X-Defiant Beta? Das wollte ich mir auch noch mal
zu Gemüte führen.
X-Deviant.
Chico.
Das Wort gefällt Chico.
Auch wenn es komplett falsch ausgesprochen ist.
Chico,
X-Deviant.
Was sagst du dazu?
Chico, was sagst du?
Die denkt jetzt auch, Alter, geh mir nicht
auf den Sack, Mann.
Die hat gerade äußerst irritiert auf den Schrank geguckt.
Obwohl, Leute, die Closed Beta hatten gestern
schon. Ja, okay.
Äh, Chat,
was ist das für eine Map?
Ich dachte, das ist Eureka Harbor,
aber das ist nicht Eureka Harbor.
Ah, ah, Schiff, Schiff.
Schiff Map. Okay.
Schiffke.
Okay, wir probieren mal was.
Das kann aber durchaus sein, dass das ab...
Das ist übrigens nicht... Oh, shit.
Das ist übrigens nicht das, was ich probieren wollte.
Okay, nice. Spawnpunkt.
Oh, shit.
Alter, Boris, Mann.
Ich hasse diesen Kack.
Diesen... Diesen...
Diesen Dreckspecialist, Alter.
Der fuckt mich so ab, der Schild, Mann.
Der, der... Ne, nicht Boris.
Alter, wie komm ich immer auf... Dozer, Mann.
Wie komm ich immer auf Boris?
Jetzt aber.
Sag mal, lass mich doch mal wenigstens
spawnen und irgendwas machen.
Läuft bei uns, würde ich sagen.
Läuft bei uns.
Ich glaub, wir werden grad
spawnraped.
Kann das sein?
Okay, die Schüsse sind durchgeflogen.
GG-Game. Easy.
Kann es sein, dass der Typ mich
360 noch auscorpen will?
What the...
Ich glaube, wir werden spawnraped gerade.
Ist das... Ist das möglich, ja?
Sehe ich das...
Sieht das... Sieht das so aus?
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, Wuti.
Alter.
An jeder fucking Stelle sitzt da
so ein Sniper-Dude, Mann.
Ey.
Okay, die Runde sucked.
Alter, sag mal!
Okay, okay, okay. Der Dude, der wird's hier.
Der wird's. Lass mich spawnen.
Lass mich spawnen. Spawn geh.
Jawohl, perfekt.
Ey, die sind ultra scharf, die Gegner, Mann.
Die checken immer, aus welcher Ecke
man beschossen wird.
LOL!
Da sind drei Leute in die Granate gespawnt.
Keck.
Ey.
Der Schild-Typ.
Der regt
mich so auf.
Oh shit, PP geaimt. Richtig PP geaimt.
Shit.
Ich darf nicht Dauerfeuer machen, Leute.
Ich darf nicht Dauerfeuer machen.
Sonst hätte ich drei Leute eben killen können.
Wo ist der andere?
Okay, also...
Mehr kann ich
gerade nicht machen. Ich kill wirklich alles,
was geht, aber...
Alter, lass...
Game! Fucking Game!
Ich will an den Spawn-Point.
Okay, YOLO.
Oh, oh. Okay.
Alter, warum sind die so oft
zack? Ja, das stimmt schon.
Wenn ich einfach alles killen würde, easy.
Oh, jetzt kommt... Shit, Mann!
Was ist mit den Gegnern los? Warum sind die so gut?
Oder besser gesagt,
wir können auch sagen, warum ist mein Team so scheiße, aber...
Wir blamen.
Wir blamen ja nicht die Teammates.
Das würden wir ja nie machen.
Habe ich noch nie gemacht. Ich habe noch nie gesagt,
es liegt an meinem Team.
Okay, okay.
Komm jetzt hier.
Gib ihm.
Volle Pulle.
Ran, ran. Jawohl.
Lege Hände.
Okay, hier wird gecamped.
Ist da gerade oben
einer langgelaufen?
Fuck, kill him!
Alter!
Leute, pusht halt vor!
Mann! Alter!
Ey, ich
fass es nicht.
Sind schon wieder da?
Die Diffusen wieder!
Alter, mein Plan war durch, ne?
Ich sag's nur.
Mein Plan war durch.
Aber gab's nicht.
Die haben uns richtig wegge...
Moment.
Das ist ja jugendfreier Stream.
Wobei, das ist Stream nur für Erwachsene.
Heute darf ich's ja sagen.
Die haben uns richtig weggefickt.
Ihr musstet ja alle am Anfang des Streams zustimmen,
dass es hier für Major...
Wie heißt das?
Majore oder sowas.
Audiences ist.
Englisch-FTW.
Oh, guck mal, was haben wir denn da?
Da gibt es
ein...
Ich wollte einen Silencer
dran machen, Game.
Es wäre nett, wenn ich das machen dürfte.
Bad Company 2 oder Battlefield 3?
Ich hab beides gern gespielt.
Äh, Moment mal.
Nein, nein, nein.
Das da?
Das da? Okay.
Und was haben wir hier für zur Auswahl?
Aim down sights.
Courtesy while moving.
Ja.
Komm.
Also, ich würde sagen,
BC3.
Also, wenn ich mich wirklich entscheiden müsste,
würde ich sagen, BC3.
Äh, BF3. BC3.
Ja, BC3, doch. Ohne Scheiß. Wenn ich mich entscheiden müsste,
welches Game lieber machen, dann BC3.
Aber BC3 können sie nicht machen.
BC3 oder BF6?
BC3.
Da hätte ich extremst Bock drauf.
Übrigens, warum sind diese Guns
eigentlich so ultra mies?
Äh, nein, Game. Ich wollte da nicht hochklettern.
Okay, lege Hänne.
Die wissen, dass ich...
Okay, ich hab's probiert.
Captain Poggers am Start.
Moin, willst mitspielen?
Wahrscheinlich hast du's gar nicht mehr installt.
Moment.
Oh, shit. Ah, ich hab Reload.
Oh, aua.
Brut-Hater.
Und bist wieder durch?
Ab und zu spiel ich immer noch
paar Runden ganz gerne.
Und das, obwohl das eigentlich
das schlechtste Battlefield seit Jahren ist.
Okay, wir probieren mal was.
Nein, nein, wir probieren nix.
Wir sind instant dead, gell?
Wobei zwei Medics da rumhampeln.
Also, wenn wir Glück haben...
Nee, die haben keinen Bock.
Oh, doch!
Nice, danke schön, Pog.
By the way.
Oh, shit.
Shit.
Oh, krasser Dude, Alter.
Nice.
Ich rät's dich, wenn der Typ weg ist.
Fuck.
Alter, der Depp, Mann,
auf'm Dach.
Hast du was von X-Defy mitbekommen?
Ja, ich wollt das jetzt am Wochenende
mir mal zu Gemüte... Was am Wochenende?
Nee, morgen. Wochenende.
Alles voll, shit.
Äh, wie...
Onkel Hank, wie wär's mit Fahren?
Ich hab die erste Base, glaub ich, noch nie verloren.
Onkel Hank, beweg dich halt vorwärts, Mensch.
Alter.
Okay.
Medic, Medic, Medic, Medic.
Das ist gesmoked, das ist gesmoked.
Das ist gesmoked.
Okay, wir müssen mal hier...
Okay, nice.
GG, it's game.
Der wusste einfach, dass ich genau da stehe.
Wir haben nicht mal
viele Tickets, also wir müssen jetzt...
Das...
Jetzt muss es gehen, aber geht nicht.
Geht nicht.
Okay, vielleicht können wir auch da rum.
Jawohl, Legehenne.
Sehr gut.
Krasse Legehenne am Start.
Game. Alter, ich raste
bei dem Game aus, wenn es so komische Dinger
macht. Das Game ist geil, ne?
Du willst einfach nur um die Ecke
springen und es klettert auf den Zaun
Pfahl da hoch. Okay, wir
haben es. Meine Güte, schwere Geburt,
Alter.
Massive schwere Geburt.
Boah, die Gegner sind aber auch hart drauf
gerade. Die sind richtig, richtig
scharf auf uns.
Oh, shit.
Wenn ich Glück hab, ist da oben
free.
Das hast du dir jetzt so gedacht, gell?
Das hast du dir
so gedacht, Kollege.
Kurz Klimaanlage ausschalten.
ESL. Ja, richtig ist es
ESL Final wieder.
Okay, okay.
What?
Hopp, hopp, hopp, hopp. Volle Pulle, volle Pulle.
Wir dürfen übrigens
nicht direkt. Wir müssen von hier rein.
Okay, da steht nichts.
Da steht nichts. Legehenne, Legehenne time.
Oh, ich höre einen Gegner
über mir. Okay.
Okay.
Irgendwo da hinten.
Irgendwo da hinten ist er.
Ja, Kollege, also ganz so dämlich sind wir auch nicht.
Wir sind vielleicht ein bisschen
PP-Grad-Team, aber ganz so easy
ist es auch nicht.
Aber gut, hier ist ja eh nichts mehr.
Hier ist, glaube ich,
keiner, der redzt. Doch, hier unten ist ein
Medic. Aber das ist wirklich
enorm Risiko, hier raus
zu gehen in dem Moment.
Wir spawnen bei uns ein Medic rein.
Kubik. Oh, ne,
der ist dead. Nein, ist nicht dead.
Kubik.
Kubik, six head time.
Okay, ich gehe da rein.
Oh man, Game, please. Spawnen, spawnen,
spawnen.
Shit, shit, shit, shit.
Alter, wieder um die Ecke
geschoben. So.
Ja, Kubit, Kubit.
Nice, nice, nice. Da müssen wir rein.
Da geht es jetzt rein, weil wir Glück haben noch.
Da geht es rein. Excellent.
Ähm.
Das ist mir ein bisschen
risikoreich gerade.
Shit, Alter. Von
allen Ecken.
Ich weiß ernsthaft gerade gar nicht,
wo ich hingucken soll. Ich glaube,
ich sollte einfach ein bisschen defensiver
spielen.
Oder auch nicht.
Okay, wieder alle dead und einer am defusen.
Aber das müssten wir eigentlich haben.
Guck mal, da sind total viel...
Schnell rein, schnell ins Auto.
Pulle, pulle.
Die haben ernsthaft defused, ja. Wirklich.
Wie geht das?
Wie ist das möglich, man?
Es steht ja hier wirklich
an jeder Ecke einer.
Vielleicht kriege ich ein Rätsel. Das wäre...
Oh, nee, nee. Oh, fuck, Alter. Wie viele,
man. So, schnell, schnell.
Oh, das ist
risikoreich damit.
Ich habe aufgehört zu schießen, weil ich dachte, er ist
dead. Aber aus irgendwelchen Gründen hat nicht alles
gehittert oder ich habe nicht richtig getroffen.
Ey, wir sind dead.
Okay, schnell. Ah, shit. Wisst ihr,
was richtig geil wäre von dem Game?
Wenn man einfach jetzt
raus könnte.
Ich meine, warum bin ich gezwungen,
mir den Scheiß anzugucken?
Was ist der Sinn davon? Was für einen
Mehrwert hat das für mich,
dass ich mir das jetzt angucken muss?
Warum kann ich nicht
einfach raus? Und warum kann ich
immer noch nicht raus und ein neues Game suchen?
Warum brauche ich zwei Minuten Downtime
zwischen den Runden? Alter, man, wie scheiße,
man. Warum brauche ich
Downtime zwischen den
Runden? Oh, jetzt darf ich.
Jetzt darf ich. Ja, nice.
Also, am liebsten würde ich,
ganz ehrlich, Runde ist vorbei,
würde ich einfach ganz schnell gemacht quit,
raus.
Ich glaube, das ist, dass man...
Twitch-Zuschauer, du hast
Recht. Genau das ist der Grund.
Wer will Skins in so
einem Game, wo du eh den Gegner kaum siehst
und
dann musst
du halt alle zwingen, guckt
euch meine tollen Skins an.
Weil ansonsten kaufe ich ja nix.
Nosha Canals,
Attacker. Jawoll, nice.
Da hab ich Bock drauf. Ihr wisst,
Nosha Canals, Attacker, es spawnen
keine Attacker-Boote.
Das heißt,
entweder wir schaffen
es in der ersten Runde,
also nicht in der ersten Runde, in der ersten
Welle,
oder wir sind
dead. Also ich muss
sagen, die ACR gefällt mir besser
als die KKW 36.
Ach ja, irgendjemand hat ja gefragt,
ob BC3, BF6
und ich, wie gesagt, ich bin,
ich hab ja eben schon was zu gesagt, also
ich wär eindeutig mal wieder für BC3.
Ich wär eindeutig mal wieder für BC3,
weil
ich mal richtig Bock hätte wieder
auf ein Game im Bad Company Style.
Also auch,
ja, das ist eine blöde Landestelle,
also auch ohne hinlegen
und sowas. Ich fand das einfach
mega. Das hat die Leute
irgendwie ein bisschen dazu, ein bisschen dazu
motiviert zu ruschen. In einem Spielmodus,
der halt auch Rush...
Shit, alles
spät gesehen. In einem Spielmodus, der halt auch
Rush heißt.
Wieso hast du manchmal Black Screen?
Weil das Battlefield 2042 ist.
Das ist die einzig logische
Erklärung für dafür.
Und warum bin ich jetzt unter Wasser und sehe nix?
Weil das Battlefield 2042
ist.
Die Grafikkarte könnte zu schlecht sein, ja, ihr habt
recht. Das ist es, Chat.
Exposed.
Grafikkarte
ist zu schlecht.
Oh, was mach ich denn da?
Okay, wir probieren mal was. Wir gehen mal aufs Dach.
Oh shit,
der ist aufm Dach. Ich muss runter. Fuck.
Ich hätt's wissen müssen, dass die aufm...
Da oben! Habt ihr gesehen, wo der liegt?
Alter!
Guck mal!
Okay, schnell, schnell.
Wir müssen A. A müssen wir defenden.
Auf B kommen die nicht mehr.
Also B springen sie jetzt runter gleich. Oh, da ist
der LRV.
Das ist...
Ich weiß nicht von wo, ehrlich gesagt.
Aber man kann's probieren.
Haben wir alles? Alles dead?
Hey, alles dead. Nice.
Und man sieht die ganzen
Rumgammler mit ihrem Scope da oben
wieder.
Den ganzen Tag am Schimmeln und Scope gucken.
360 no Scope.
Wobei,
der macht ja noch nicht mal 360 no Scopes.
Der macht die ganze Zeit
äh...
Keine Ahnung.
In eine Richtung guckt, Hard Scopes.
Was anderes können die ja nicht.
Okay, das war ziemlich pipega.
Ich rett's nicht.
Nee, der macht schon, okay.
YOLO!
Ich hätt nicht gedacht, dass die mich durchlassen.
Okay.
Wow!
Richtig schön
mit der Shotgun
reingeballert, Alter.
Richtig den Hintern weggeschossen.
So.
Schnell!
Oh, zu früh, zu früh, zu früh.
Gleich bin ich dead.
Okay.
What the fuck?
Okay, mehr kann ich nicht machen, Leute.
Das war Maximum
das Mögliche.
Mehr ging nicht, aber ich glaub, wir haben's auch.
Nice.
Naisu!
Es ist mir zu viel los, mein Boomer hier
macht das nicht mit.
Game, please!
Hier, guck mal, Leute, Blech, da kann man nicht durchschießen.
In BC2 ging das zwar noch,
Leute, die Technologie
ist einfach noch nicht da.
Man muss, man muss, man muss sagen, wie's ist.
Die Technologie ist noch nicht da.
Oh.
Ich hoffe, der hat mich nicht gesehen.
Okay.
Wir flanken mal, aber da ist man halt sehr anfällig,
wenn man hier flankt, weil
von jeder Seite kann da permanent einer.
Aber wir probieren's mal, wir probieren's mal.
Okay, Game, so war das
nicht geplant.
Okay. Lege Hänne!
Lege Hänne! Massive!
Ha!
Shit.
So was Komplexes wie
durch Blech schießen muss noch erfunden werden. Ja, ist so.
Wie gesagt, die Technologie ist einfach
nicht da. Ich mein, das ging vor
zehn Jahren mal, aber ich mein,
wer weiß, was die damals
gemacht haben. Oh, da ist...
Waren die zu faul
und haben einfach die gleiche Karte von einem anderen Battlefield
genommen. Ich würde nicht sagen,
dass sie zu faul waren. Ja.
Also, ja, sie waren zu faul,
aber sie waren
auch zu unfähig.
Und dementsprechend bin ich
eigentlich ganz froh.
Ach ja, und seit wann ist das eigentlich so
mies, das Teil hier?
Moment, wir haben das noch nicht.
What the...
Boris!
Woah, woah, woah, woah.
Ach, da hinten ist noch einer.
Ah, shit. Na gut.
Okay, ich spawne lieber rein.
Ja, wir haben nämlich
hier unseren...
Oh, oh.
Ja, Boris, Boris.
Oh, Boris.
Nein! Boris macht die Legehände!
Leute, ihr Kacknubs, macht den platt!
Jawohl, sehr gut. Sehr schön.
Sehr schön.
Sehr gut. Bock. Bock!
Extrem
Bock.
Leute, ich bleib einfach mal kurz hier stehen.
Mein Boomer hier muss sich akklimatisieren.
Okay.
Weiter geht's.
Siehste, siehste?
Ist einfach zu viel für mich.
Hier ist doch einer.
Hier ist doch garantiert noch einer.
Guck, hier sah ich doch.
Keine Ahnung, wo
hier was ist. Oh, oh. Oh, oh.
Airburst.
Da!
Siehste? Da fehlt mir
einfach die Übung. Da hat man's gesehen.
Jemand Gutes, also
der auch ein bisschen FPS
mal irgendwie spielt, der hätte
aimtechnisch locker gehabt. Ich halt nicht.
Ich hab nur ein.
Und in solchen Situationen kommt's halt drauf an,
dass du eben direkt auf dem Gegner
bist und nicht...
und nicht wie ich
so komisches Zeug machst.
Oder dass man zum Beispiel auch den easy
killt. Fuck, ich
kack Noob. Ich wusste, dass du rausguckst.
Irgendwann kommt
AI-Hirn-Implementar
und dann kannst du wieder auf Suma-Niveau zocken.
Na, ich bin ja jetzt schon besser als sie.
Okay, das Game spielt keine Suma.
Spielen keine Suma.
Aber
wisst ihr, das ist eigentlich richtig next level
sich
Five-Hit-Aiming-Implantat zu
kaufen, weil
da kann man auf Suma-Niveau spielen.
Wieder als Boomer.
Und die Suma können sich das nicht
kaufen, weil die können sich das nicht leisten.
Das ist Pay-To-Win.
Real-Life-Pay-To-Win.
Komplett. Also, die Suma
haben das Geld nicht dafür, sich das zu kaufen.
Äh, okay.
Alter!
What?
Was geht denn jetzt hier gerade ab?
Jetzt macht er noch die Fuske. Ne, macht er nicht.
Das
hat mein Hirn wieder nicht mitgemacht.
Patrick, es
scheint so. Ja, ich habe das nicht
gesagt. Aber
dementsprechend hat es ja auch nicht geklappt.
Hat jemand anderes
geplantet. Ich habe es ja nur probiert.
Schauen wir mal, ob wir hier drüber kommen.
Übrigens, ich finde die Anzeige blöd von
den Sekunden.
Guckt, so kann jeder
schon losrennen und er weiß
immer genau, wann er
stirbt und wann nicht.
Das war in den alten
Battlefields eher so ein bisschen ein
Gefühlsthema, als sei denn jemand hat einen Wecker gestellt
oder so. Ich will nicht bezweifeln, dass das
manche Leute gemacht haben.
Was ich ein bisschen blöd fand.
Das ist immer, dass es jetzt so mit dem Timer
ist.
So.
Siehste? PP-Gar-Aim.
Das ist es. Da macht es die Übung einfach aus.
Oh, ich muss spawnen bei dem Typ.
Spawnen, bis er in Fight ist.
Bevor der in Fight ist. Schnell, schnell, schnell spawnen.
Nee, zu dem wollte ich nicht.
Ja, nice.
Leberwurst
mit saurer Gurke. Ja, das ist irgendwie
so ein Xbox-Name wahrscheinlich.
Ist das Crossplay-Enabled?
Das klingt,
das klingt ein bisschen wie so ein
Xbox-Generated.
Oh, wir
tun uns schwer.
Ich lass den bei mir noch spawnen.
Shit.
Geown vom Hyper-Reflex-Zoomer.
Vielleicht,
vielleicht kriege ich...
Leute, das ist...
Ich baite die ganzen Medics zum Rätzen.
Dann rushen die Leute
vielleicht... Moment, die haben schon defused.
Wie haben die denn so schnell
defused? Da war doch die ganze Zeit jemand
dran, oder? Oder nicht?
Wahrscheinlich.
Es wäre halt cool, wenn man in dem Game
drei Leute auswählen könnte. Also einzeln.
Oh, shit.
Oh.
Dead.
Okay, wir haben verloren. Das kriegen wir nicht
mehr.
Ich hätte die Chance gehabt, die Legehennen auf B
klarzumachen, wenn ich gescheit geaimt hätte.
Shit.
Chico, was ist?
Ich lass dich raus.
Kriege ich den Rätzen? Nope.
Der Boomer ist am... Ja, so ist es hier leider.
Der Boomer
muss das selbst machen, alles.
Zumindest haben wir noch
einen anderen Typ im Team, der ganz gut ist.
Das freut mich.
Äh.
Leute,
wenn die das jetzt defuse...
Alter, die kriegen es defused, man!
Leute, wie schlecht
kann man eigentlich sein? Bewegt euren
Arsch an das M, komm!
The fuck?
Wie kann man so kacke sein?
Alter, was willst du machen, ey?
Irgendwann musst du dich mal aufregen.
Wir haben eh 14...
Dings keine Chance.
Das war eine blöde Idee.
War eine ganz blöde Idee.
Ey Leute, was soll ich machen, man?
Das heißt Rush.
Genau, das heißt Rush und setzt euch nicht
den Arschwund irgendwo da hinten, man.
Guck mal, keiner da.
Keiner da.
Alter, was flaschen wieder, ey.
Fuck. Wie scheiße kann man
das Spiel nach 50 Jahren Battlefield
noch spielen, man? Guckt euch das an.
Erster. Kills erster.
Objective destroyed.
Ich bin fast 40, man!
Ihr Drecksnoobs müsst
es doch besser können als ich.
Okay, nee, 39, nicht 40.
Ja, ist echt so.
Opa Squad.
Wahrscheinlich sind die alle so alt.
Die sind wahrscheinlich...
Die sind wahrscheinlich noch
älter als ich.
Wahrscheinlich sind das hier echte Boomer.
Nicht nur Boomer, wo man Boomer sagt, sondern
echte Boomer.
Was hältst du von Durchbruch, Abstand?
Mag ich nicht.
Okay, Chat.
Eigentlich müsste ich jetzt ins Bett.
Wollen wir noch eine Runde machen?
Wir gucken mal.
Wir gucken mal, was es für
eine Map kommt.
Wir gucken, was für eine Map kommt.
Wenn es eine gute Map ist und
eine gute Fraktion ist
oder halt eine gute Rolle,
also Attacker, Defender auf der Map,
Discarded.
Okay, wir probieren mal
die erste Base.
Vielleicht Ragequit
quitt ich auch dann und geh' pennen.
Mit einem
Loose zu bannen, sorgt für... Das juckt mich nicht.
Nee, das
interessiert mich echt nicht mehr.
Ich reg mich genauso lang
auf, wie ich spiele danach. Nicht mehr.
Oh, guck mal.
Es gibt keine Bots mehr. Nice.
Wird nicht mehr mit Bots aufgefüllt.
Hat ja lang gedauert.
Dass dieser Müll verschwindet.
Ah, wir
holen die Line. Kein Problem.
Massive Line Holding.
Auf der Playstation 5
bekommt man und muss Cosplay anmachen.
Alter, guckt euch das mal an.
Diese Maps. Alter,
wie scheiße die Maps sind, man.
Guck mal, die haben das
M-Comp zur Hälfte down, bevor du als
Defender die Chance hast, überhaupt ins M-Comp
ranzukommen.
So schlecht.
Als ob du gegen Keyboard-Leute zockst.
Naja, du hast Auto-Aim
und
du kannst halt
gegen echte Menschen spielen und nicht nur gegen Bots.
Also insofern
solltest du Cosplay
spielen, würde ich sagen.
Okay, jo.
Nice.
RPG.
On-Inf-RPG.
Okay, der hat keinen Bock, mich zu retzen.
Hat aber auch recht.
Ja, du kannst
Maus und Tastatur
anschließen an die PS5, aber ich finde
ganz ehrlich,
dass sich das nicht so schön spielt.
Dank
60 FPS. Wobei
ich gar nicht weiß,
ob das nicht, wenn man das
spielt auf der neueren
Plattform.
Kann man, kann man eigentlich
das auf der PS5 spielen?
Kann man damit 120 spielen?
Nice, voll in den Kopf
geschossen, passiert nichts.
Bam, dead.
Hab ich
nicht gesagt, ich spiele nur erste Base?
Okay, ich spiele zweite Base,
spiele ich auch noch.
Das ist mal ein schöner Effekt, wie die Dinger explodieren.
Gefällt mir. Mal eine Sache
ganz schön gemacht in dem Spiel.
Oh nice, da rutschen wir jetzt rein.
Es war aber richtig
dämlich, Alter. Da rutschen wir jetzt rein.
Ich wusste nicht, dass die schon runtergucken.
Aber, Leute, wo seid ihr denn?
Teamge!
Äh, nein.
Nein, nein, nein. Zu dem gehe ich nicht.
Zum Solo-Sniper gehe ich nicht.
Hey, Balance ist okay.
Wir sucken einfach.
Was halt zackt, ist diese Geschichte...
Ja, fuck it, Alter. Wir waren zu weit vorne.
Was halt zackt, ist die
Geschichte mit...
Die denken halt auch mit, einfach.
Was halt kacke ist, ist, dass die Leute
einfach schon
am M kommen sind, bevor
die Defender eine Chance haben, überhaupt
hinzukommen. Das ist halt...
Das ist halt schon mies.
Ja, ja.
Ist mir auch klar.
What the hell, Alter.
Ich weiß überhaupt nicht...
Ich weiß ja nicht mal, wo...
Da ist einer.
Da haben sich zwei Pepegas getroffen,
gerade.
Er trifft mich nicht, ich treffe ihn nicht.
Ah, okay. Man kann es ja
mal probieren.
Richtig potatoed, ja.
Sind wir denn hier gelandet?
Boah, ich nupe.
Oh, shit.
Wie? Och, Mann, ich wollte
ihn mit der Tonne killen.
Noch nicht mal das funktioniert in dem Game.
Pepegaspiel, Alter.
Richtiges
Pepega-Game.
Hyper-Pepega-Game.
Wozu...
Wirklich. Legit.
Frage. Wozu sind die Tonnen da, wenn
einer zwei Meter daneben steht und ich stirb,
wenn du die in die Luft jagst?
Wow.
Okay. Sehr gut, Mann.
Boah, die Leute
sind so schlecht alle wieder.
Also, ich muss ehrlich
sagen, ich hab sogar
letztens mal morgens
ein Spiel am Wochenende
und, also irgendwann morgens um sieben oder so
als ich morgens aufgewacht bin,
ein paar Runden
und
ich hab Instant Lobbys gefunden. Also, es geht
zur Zeit. Also, ich kann jedem nur empfehlen,
wenn ihr noch mal Bock auf das Game habt,
dann spielt es jetzt noch ein paar Runden, weil
das ist wahrscheinlich die
vorletzte Season, die es gibt.
Oh, ganz blöde Idee, Max.
Also, insofern,
jetzt hat es halt noch Spieler.
In the Hood ist er.
Okay, was auch immer. Einfach mal
in die Richtung geballert.
Vorletzte Season, ja. Naja, also,
Season 5 ist ja schon
die erste Season, die sie nicht hätten machen müssen.
Es wurde Season 6 angekündigt
und ich geh halt mal davon aus,
wenn die Gerüchte stimmen, dass Battlefield 6
kommt, nächstes
Jahr schon,
dann, ja,
dann war's das.
Ich mein, ich spiel
hier auch kaum noch einer. Aber jetzt
könnt ihr halt noch mal spielen. Jetzt hat es Spieler
abends. 10k Spieler, was halt lächerlich
wenig eigentlich ist für einen BF, aber
besser als nix.
Oh, shit. Wir müssten da mal ran.
Diffuse da einer?
Diffuske? Leute,
Diffuse... Alter,
der Boomer, ne? Der Boomer muss alles
selber machen.
Und jetzt bin ich dead.
Weil mein Team einfach nur wieder richtig hirnlose
Ketten sind, die nix auf die Reihe bekommen.
Guckt euch das an! Guckt euch
das Elend an!
Ich hätte es easy von oben halten können,
aber nein, es geht ja keiner ran.
Battlefield 6
mit Scoreboard Legacy Features.
Das ist auch nur in dem Game drin, weil sich
die Leute zu sehr aufgeregt haben.
Oh.
Es sind noch 7 Tickets. Ich camp jetzt hier und warte
auf das M-Com.
Ich bleib einfach genau hier sitzen und warte, bis die
Tickets vorbei sind.
Wobei, ne, ich geh da hoch.
Hier ist es besser.
Oh, massive.
Erster schon erwischt.
Also wenn die das jetzt noch kriegen, dann uninstall ich das Game.
Direkt Instant
Rage Quit.
Da war Boris wieder.
Oh.
Ein Videospiel jetzt sogar
kürzer als sein Toaster.
Das sind Videospiele, die
mit einem
ich will nicht sagen schlechten Launch,
das war ja noch nicht mal mehr ein schlechter Launch,
das war schon ein
desaströser Launch
gestartet sind.
Und
die wahrscheinlich auch nicht sonderlich viel Geld
machen, weil wie auch
wenn es kaum einer spielt
und eigentlich sich die Leute nur lustig machen
über das Game.
Mittlerweile würde ich sagen,
könnte man das Spiel
dran denken zu releasen Ende des Jahres.
Also wisst ihr,
wenn die sich jetzt noch mal richtig reinhängen würden,
bis September, November,
da könnten sie ein gutes Battlefield
releasen mit dem Spiel.
Also müssten noch ein paar Sachen eingebaut werden.
Blöd ist halt, dass das Game schon fast
zwei Jahre raus ist.
Die sollen einfach nicht DICE das Battlefield entwickeln
lassen. Warum muss es
DICE machen? Mal ganz im Ernst, von den Battlefield
Kennern dort ist doch eigentlich keiner mehr da.
Können die das nicht
irgendwann irgendeinem Studio geben, was mega
Bock hat drauf ein gutes Battlefield zu machen?
Die andere Seite ist jetzt ja
der Apex-Chef,
der Ex-Apex-Chef bei DICE,
hat er jetzt auch das Sagen.
Aber ich weiß halt nicht, ob der aus dem
DICE-Haufen noch was Gescheites
rausholen kann. Ich hab da keinen...
Ich truste nicht mehr.
Leute, Bettgeteilt.
Ich muss pennen. Wir sehen uns denn
morgen oder so. Mal gucken.
Bis dann. Tschü.